so i have a friend of mine who's on a
lot of dating apps and he asked me
recently he said hey can you make a
video with me and let's put it on top of
one of my dating profiles
it's getting really competitive out
there and i was like okay
i said what do you want to do and he
said let's make it funny so we made it
funny but he didn't tell
any truths about himself in the video
and i asked him i go why don't you tell
the truth about yourself
and he said nobody tells the truth about
themselves on dating apps
he said i showed up on one day and this
girl had a different face and i was like
what
and he asked me he said would you tell
the truth about yourself and i said yeah
and he said would you make a video and i
said no i'd probably write a stupid
little song
so this is the song that i would have on
top of my dating profile
to let people know a little bit about
myself here you go
[Music]
you know that i want you baby
you know that i need you baby
you know that i got you baby
[Music]
so come let me please you baby
but i have sex with my socks on
i have sex with my black sock song girl
i have sex with my socks on
i have sex with my black socks on girl
got bad circulation baby
[Music]
my feet are like ice cubes baby
deep vein thrombosis baby
[Music]
i'm on medication baby
that's why i have sex with my socks on
i have sex with my black sox song girl
[Music]
a couple other things i should probably
tell you
my legs are pale they're almost kind of
light blue
there's a chance that i'll dutch of in
you
oh and my stamina is not what it used to
be
so when we bang you gonna get on top but
i'll have my
socks on
and i'll have my black socks on
girl and i
also i
also
[Music]
shave my
[Music]
eyebrows
i think we got it how do you feel
[Music]
terrible
[Music]
[Music]
you